Замість могили – лише пам'ятний камінь
на цвинтарі литовського села Тільтагаліаі
Батько Дайнори Урбоніене зник безвісти у Сибіру
куди його депортували у сталінські табори
Востаннє жінка бачила тата на вокзалі
у квітні 1940 року
Діти страшенно плакали і бігли до батьків
дружини рвалися до чоловіків
проте солдати усіх відтіснили
Дайнору, її матір та маленького братика теж розлучили з батьком
Переглядаючи архівні фото
жінка розповідає, як разом з іншими депортованими литовцями
долала тисячі кілометрів у вагонах для худоби
на вантажівках та пішки
Через весь Радянський Союз - до Алтаю
Братик помирає ще в дорозі.
В Сибіру вони живуть у бараках посеред лісу
Мати разом з іншими жінками виконує
тяжку фізичну роботу
Однак найбільше дошкуляли холод і голод
пригадує Дайнора
У завірюху харчі депортованим не доставляли
тож якось їй з матір'ю довелося місяць виживати
маючи лише 63 картоплини
Що саме радянська влада закидала її батькам
Дайнора Урбоніене не знає досі
Ймовірно, для підозри достатньо було того
що обоє були вчителями
тобто належали до литовської еліти
У Центрі дослідження геноциду
й опору жителів Литви у Вільнюсі
зібрані документи й артефакти тих часів
Після приходу радянської влади у 1940 році
понад 200 тисяч литовців
більше 10 відсотків населення –
були депортовані до Сибіру
Багатьох з них катували
та допитували у підвалах цієї будівлі
Особливо постраждали державні службовці
фермери і вчителі
тому що через їхні погляди і ставлення до радянської влади
вони на її розсуд нібито були найбільш небезпечними елементами
для радянської влади
Соціально-небезпечним елементом Дайнора Урбоніене вважалася
аж до розпаду СРСР
Відтоді її донька, депутатка Раса Юкневічіене добивається
визнання та відшкодування російським урядом
заподіяного її матері
та іншим жертвам репресій і депортацій
Поки безуспішно
Російський уряд не цікавиться
стражданнями жертв у той період
Нині в Росії Сталін знову в тренді
з'являються пам'ятники, фільми
виринають неправдиві спогади, які стверджують
що він був лідером і засновником державності
Навіть у заснованій російським мільйонером литовській Партії праці
критично оцінюють позицію Росії
Це не питання грошей
Найважливіше – визнати історію
правильно її оцінити, а не заперечувати окупацію
заперечувати її наслідки
Дайнора Урбоніене каже,
що не відчуває ненависті до росіян
але той факт, що Росія не визнає
вчинених у Литві злочинів
жінка сприймає як нову загрозу
Ненависть не поверне мені мого батька і брата
Я хочу лише, щоб подібне
більше ніколи не повторилося